Edson Arantes de nacimento was born in
1940 18 years before his Sublime skills
of the ball would earn football the
nickname the beautiful game to Brazil
Pele was everything a prodigy a
superstar
a Talisman I got the gift from God to
play football and then my father used to
say listen he feels you got to give it
from God to play if you'll be in good
shape nobody stop you
outside the hospital where he was put in
palliative care his fans licked candles
and contemplated a world without Pele
never again will football have a Pele
says this fan never again will football
enchant the planet as it did when he
laced up his cleats
Pele played the majority of his career
for the Brazilian Club Santos
although the big clubs in Europe were
certainly interested in 1958 Santos was
forced to tear up a contract agreeing to
send Pele to Italy after fans revolted a
few years later the Brazilian government
declared him an official national
treasure an actual law preventing Santos
from making millions in transfer fees
from foreign clubs confined to playing
in Brazil Pele did what he did best
scoring goals in leading Brazil to three
World Cup wins on the way to becoming
the first black Global Superstar his
influence was such that in 1969 two
factions in the Nigerian civil war
agreed to a 48-hour ceasefire so they
could watch Pele play an exhibition
match I met him many many times in South
America or wherever you know the the
global football Community comes together
is just such a wonderful person and he's
been the greatest of all there's no
doubt about it
he finished his career playing in the
U.S for the New York Cosmos drawing sold
out crowds in a country that was somehow
in awe of Pele while not fully
understanding the game he dominated
after hanging up his cleats he devoted
his time to Children's Charities and
improving social conditions for the
poorest in Brazil and his Brazil Sports
Minister he stayed clear of the
corruption that would engulf football
drafting legislation to create more
transparency and fairness one of his
teammates once marveled at his Fame
saying in some countries they wanted to
touch him and some they wanted to kiss
him and others they even kissed the
ground He Walked on how beautiful is
that
Mike drolet Global News